that was a
disaster of a game uh over quickly uh
just showed you one team that is truly
on a dynasty level with another team
that is in rebuild mode with a young
quarterback and
the dynasty mode team showed that that
other team doesn't deserve to be on the
field with them
and you know the patriots took full
advantage of that mini buy plus a day to
prepare for the new york jets to figure
out how to dismantle the new york jets
and they did dismantle them effectively
and thoroughly and completely it wasn't
close from the beginning of the game to
the end
and look the patriots offense looked
better than it has for a while they
started the game with a long drive
longest opening
of the game drive all year long for the
patriots but it's that defense that is
operating on a level that we have never
seen a patriots defense operate on
they've always had a good defense at
times they've had a great defense chris
this year it is
next level ultranext level suffocation
interception turnover machine shut you
down turn your quarterback into a guy
who looks like he doesn't belong on the
field yeah well there's so many things
to go here too i mean first of all to
talk about the patriots it's phenomenal
talent it's bill belichick being the
defensive coordinator and having you
know his hands uh involved in the daily
details more than ever before and hey
this just in he's their best coach he's
the best coach there ever was and when
he gets into game specifics like that uh
like he does right now as the de facto d
coordinator it is another level of game
planning they have a secondary that of
course is extremely talented and maybe
uh the best in football
and because of that secondary they're
like backwards where most teams in
football their front seven does things
to help their secondary in new england
they go our secondary is so good we're
gonna screw you over with all the things
we can do with our front seven we're
just gonna play man-to-man and we're
gonna bring blitzes and they just expose
the jets mike exposed adam gase and sam
darnold really that there was no
contingency plan it was blitz after
blitz after blitz in big situations
during the game and sam darnold didn't
know anything about his protections and
i don't know if adam gases offense
always had the right built-in throws to
get the ball out of his hands in some of
those situations against the blitz sorry
for the long answer there but it was
just i was excited and i had a lot to
say
well no and it look it it it was
stunning to see how many times sam
darnold slipped into that
close your eyes throw the ball and hope
for the best right right he would he
would even when there wasn't someone
coming at times and that's that's where
we get into this notion of him saying
while miked up during the game i'm
seeing ghosts he wasn't seeing ghosts in
the secondary adam gase explained after
the game these were ghosts that he
thought were blitzers that were coming
at him right but you know at a certain
point don't you just have to throw the
ball away don't you just have to take
the sack this idea that i've got
pressure right in my face so i'm just
going to throw the ball up in the air
and it's going to go right into the
hands of a patriot at some point that's
just unacceptable isn't it yeah it is i
mean he he started to fade away from
throws and just oh i'm not sure exactly
what i'm seeing but i'm just gonna throw
it out there and see what happens yes he
did not manage those situations
correctly and yeah he saw ghost because
he he didn't know what exactly was going
on i mean that's really all there is to
it now you know if you heard booger
mcfarland he made a comment that sam
darnold talked about you know during his
time off he was going to brush up on
pass protections and things like that
well new england saw something in the
film that go i'm not so sure sam darnold
knows what to do against the blitz or
how to readjust his offensive line in
pass protection at this point of his
young career and they just said you know
i think we're gonna test that and check
it out and it goes to the very first
interception the very first interception
if we could play that again they know
that play is coming they know that's the
bliss blitz adjust adjustment if you
want to show it there in the back
production room because he knew they
would like to throw this slot out look
at devon mccourty on the outside mike he
didn't cover his guy so i could almost
promise you that new england said hey
when they bring that blitz they're going
to throw the slot out route or maybe the
back shoulder fade on the outside just
stand there and the ball is going to
come your way when we bring this blitz
and of course they were right and i
think they did that a number of times
during the game last night to sam
darnold company
all right i got two questions for you on
this first one is that you know we talk
about blueprints all the time when
someone cracks the code on a great
offense or a great defense and that
becomes the blueprint going forward have
the pay and not that the jets are a
great offense by any stretch yeah but if
the patriots given the rest of the jets
opponents the blueprint for turning sam
darnold into the guy that we saw last
night well it's going to make sam
darnold and the new york jets go back to
the drawing board from here on out
because yes you can you can you can
guarantee that next week whoever they
play is going to go well let's see if
they fix some of these blitz issues that
they just had against new england and
they're going to have to probably prove
themselves a few times in the first half
to say oh no sam's brushed up on it we
got the offensive line right we got the
right plan to where it's going to back a
team off of it but if if they start to
you know show that they're not
fundamentally sound once again next week
it will become a common theme week after
week after week we know it's a copycat
league until you fix these issues
yeah and look i i
i don't understand how a guy who was so
highly touted coming out of college
in year two and i know it takes time and
we talk about how you get to a point
usually when you're in your early
thirties we talked about russell wilson
last week in this way that he's in year
eight he's seen a lot of things so he
knows how to adjust he knows how to
react he knows how to adapt
it's going to take a while it looks like
for sam darnold to get to that point and
the question is
how hard will it be for him to recover
from this do you do you run the risk of
of breaking him right mentally uh i mean
and i know i've heard that in the
context of other quarterbacks in the
past maybe lesser quarterbacks but would
you be concerned what would you say to
him today if you're walking into the
quarterback room and you're the position
coach yeah how do you fix him in the
aftermath of what we saw last night well
you fix them by telling them first he's
not the the first quarterback to have a
horrible night against the new england
patriots this year or over their 19-year
run
and the next thing you say is this is a
learning experience this is this you try
to frame it that way like yes there is
an issue with our offense and in your
game sam darnold that we need to fix and
we got to get after it right now and
that's what new england realized they
cracked the code and realizing ah i'm
not so sure their contingency plan for
all our blitzes is up to par and that's
what they tested and that's the things
that sam donald's gonna have to go back
i don't think you're gonna break them i
do think this is a very mentally strong
kid
i've been around him enough to know that
he's not going to get too up or down
either way
but this is going to make him go back
and you know cross the t's and dot the
eyes a little bit with the
blitz protection and how he should get
the bot of his hands if they can't
protect it you know there was a lot of
times there last night mike where you
know
on the telecast we're talking about it
and we're going oh this guy messed up
but here on this instance right there
there's not enough people to pick up the
blitzer so there's not enough blockers
so that's on sam darnold that's not the
coaching staff or the offensive lineman
a number of those were just sam
darnold's got to realize they have more
than he can pick up
and
you know the the schedule softens
eventually for the jets they go to
jacksonville this week short week it's
not like the jaguars don't have the
horses to try to replicate what the
patriots did on monday night right but
some winnable games are looming for the
jets and i think the challenge for adam
gase is going to be to get this kid
reset quickly this is only his third
game played this year and even though
he's healthy enough to play he's fought
through this mono and and maybe he's
still in the process of getting back to
where he needs to be it really is
stunning though to consider chris he was
the afc offensive player of the week
yeah in
week six with that win over the cowboys
and to fall the way he's fallen and look
i think if you're gay you just explain
to him sometimes this happens sometimes
the game gets out of hand early
sometimes
it just
it just doesn't work but that doesn't
mean it's never going to work again and
i think the sooner they can get back on
the horse and and get a win under their
belt and have a game where it flows like
it flowed against the cowboys maybe the
fact that that was just a week and two
days ago will make it easier for donald
to accept and understand that it doesn't
mean he suddenly can't play quarterback
but as of last night it looked like the
guy suddenly can't play quarterback yeah
no
you know a lot of the issues you know i
think that some of his negative coming
out of usc was him taking care of the
football i mean that was the biggest
problem he led the ncaa in turnovers his
last year at usc uh and that kind of
reared its ugly head last night but you
know this is against a
all-time team right now and you know
that just it just seems inevitable the
patriots are going to the super bowl
okay and it seems like if i had a bet
they're going to play the san francisco
49ers right now i'm locking it in all
right i'm saying 49ers new england
patriot super bowl but on both sides of
the ball
it's just phenomenal it's just it's just
surgical dissection uh and there's a
contingency plan i mean even on the
offense mike you know i mean look at
brady last night and the things they do
there's no he doesn't even audible
because every play has a contingency
plan for every defense and it's
unbelievable
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports